j'ai eu l'expérience des comportements
inappropriés de patrick poivre d'arvor
d' ces gestes inconvenants parole
inconvenant dans un cadre aussi qu'ils
étaient il ya son mode de fonctionnement
l'invitation journal du 20h et ensuite
dans l'escalier de secours effectivement
il a tenté voilà d'avoir des relations
avec moi mais j'ai dit non il a respecté
mon nom et ensuite j'ai voulu avoir une
confrontation avec lui pour connaître
pour avoir une explication sur son
comportement évidemment ça a dégénéré
voilà donc c'est ce que j'ai raconté la
dernière fois alors quand vous dites que
ça a dégénéré sais ce que c'est à dire
c'est à dire qu'il est devenu un peu
violent parce que effectivement il
supportait pas à mon insistance et ses
questions sur voila je lui demandais de
s'expliquer et voyait pas pourquoi il
devait s'expliquer sur son comportement
pour autant oui vous avez résumé en
quelques mots à ses expériences à la
fois de vous admiratrice de pâtés
salades avant que cela vous aviez
sollicité exhale rentrée et en même
temps c'est c'est je ne sais même pas
comment le qualifier c'est à dire ses
tentatives on va dire oui c'est qu'ils
se sont même soldée par une forme de
violence à votre égard et tour temps et
c'est pour ça qu'on nous avions tous été
un peu interpellé vous le défendez dié
et vous le défendez toujours vous faites
partie de ce jury littéraire beaucoup
d'autres sont partis de ce jury et vous
vous dites non je reste encore une fois
pour que mickael raison et même je l'ait
maintenue on l'a maintenu
membres du jury en 2021 voilà suite aux
révélations et malgré tout même âge et
malgré les huit femmes les huit femmes
qui témoignent dans libération malgré
les témoignages qui sont alors je sais
présomption d'innocence on va évidemment
le répéter mais qui sont pour le coup
quand même accablant malgré votre
expérience personnelle malgré cela vous
dit non seulement même s'il veut se
retirer du jury je le maintiens mais en
plus moi j'y reste et je dis haut et
fort je suis aux côtés de patrick
maugard voyez moi je suis pour une
parole de la femme qui peut s'exprimer
aussi qu'on peut entendre une parole
plus nuancée ou le témoignage est
important où on peut raconter des
événements qui ont été inconvenant
déplacer c'est important de les raconter
je trouve que ça fait avancer le débat
c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire raconter
mon expérience
déplacer avec qui était vraiment
inacceptable avec patrick poivre d'arvor
mais en même temps voilà je veux pas me
substituer à la justice et aussi je peux
analyser les choses avec recul moi j'ai
réglé la question et j'estime qu'on peut
pas à juger des faits d'il ya quinze ans
avec les verts d'aujourd'hui vous
comprenez néanmoins et notamment les
auteurs qui étaient présents dans ce
jury qui sont les uns après les autres
tous désistés alors on parle de jean
paul enthoven on parle de à mamers on
parle david foenkinos à éviter les
insolations sainghinois vous j'attends
votre version annoncée c'est tout à fait
vrai mais vous lier leurs délicieux par
lier leur départ aux accusations de ppd
met 8 tout à fait mais en fait lui
s'était désisté bien avant non il s'est
désisté mais à la limite se sont pas
désistés d'ailleurs retiré le 12
novembre pour ne pas embarrasser un prix
littéraire naissant et s'est retiré dans
son ne pas embarrasser un prix
littéraire naissance est un doux
euphémisme pour pas dire ma présence
pose sauce pose question donc je fais
pas je m'en vais avait informé
effectivement lorsque les avait reçus
les démissions des ans et des élites
vous n'êtes pas de vous vous êtes dit
peut-être qu'effectivement il posait
question il posait problème et qu'il
fallait le débarquer ben je me suis posé
la question après c'était pas mon point
de vue je voyais pas que venait faire un
débat de société que venait faire des
questions qui relèvent de la justice et
du débat de société dans a redonné moi
mais tu m'aimes vous porte vous faites
porter votre prix par un bar une
personnalité qui est a minima
problématique donc c'est normal que
cette personnalité la lll
raisonne sur l'ensemble de votre prix et
donc on se dit c'est normal que les uns
et les autres prennent position et se
disent ben je veux pas être associé à
cet homme là où au contraire j'assume
complètement d'être associés à cet
honneur moi je respecte la décision
quand ils vous ont appelé pour vous dire
je par exemple amanda sthers ou jean
paul enthoven quand il vous appelle pour
vous dire je m'en vais qu'est-ce qu'il
vous dise s'est passé comment ils disent
allez vous-en voir ce que ça
décrédibilise la parole des autres
victimes plusieurs disent qu'on peut
plus faire confiance à la présomption la
vrai sens voilà ce sont les termes jean
paul hart lane n'a jamais dit ça vous
connaissez bien et n'a jamais dit cela
mais bien eu viol anal other donc non il
annonce à manger rectifier les jeux
pourris jean paul enthoven j'ai jamais
dit ça jean paul enthoven me dit n'avoir
jamais reçu les livres de la sélection
malgré l'adresse qui était correct mais
il ya plein de gens dans le jury ça a
été le cas apparemment ça pas été très
clair non ils ont tous dit avoir reçu
les livres m'ont internationaux amanda
sthers elle a démissionné parce qu'elle
m'a dit qu'elle pouvait plus faire
confiance à la présomption d'innocence